let's say someone walks up to the on the
street and they give you this expression
x squared plus 7x
plus 10 divided by
x plus 2 and they say see if you could
simplify this thing
and so
pause this video and see if you can do
that and one way to think about it is
what is x squared plus x squared plus 7x
plus 10 divided by x plus 2 what is that
going to be
all right now there's two ways that you
could approach this one way is to try to
factor the numerator and see if it has a
factor that is common to the denominator
so let's try to do that so we've done
this many many times if this is if this
looks new to you i encourage you to
review factoring polynomials other
places on khan academy but what two
numbers add up to seven and when you
multiply them you get ten
well that would be two and five so we
could rewrite that numerator as x plus
two
times x plus five and then of course the
denominator you still have x plus 2
and then we clearly see we have a common
factor and so as long as x does not
equal negative 2 because if x equals
negative 2 this whole expression is
undefined because then you get a 0 in
the denominator so as long as x does not
equal negative 2 well then we can divide
the numerator and the denominator by x
plus 2. once again the reason why i put
that constraint is we can't divide the
numerator and denominator by zero so for
any other values of x this x plus 2 will
be non-zero and we could divide the
numerator and the denominator by that
and they would cancel out and we would
just be left with
x plus 5.
so another way to think about it is this
expression our original expression could
be viewed as x plus 5 for any x that is
not equal to
negative 2.
now the other way that we could approach
this is through algebraic long division
which is very analogous to the type of
long division that you might remember
from i believe it was fourth grade
so what you do is you say all right i'm
going to divide x plus 2 into
x squared plus 7x
plus 10.
and in this technique you look at the
highest degree terms so you have an x
there and an x squared there you say how
many times does x go into x squared
well it goes x times now you would write
that in this column because x is just x
to the first power you could view this
as the first degree column it's
analogous to the place values that we
talk about when we first learn numbers
or how we regroup or or about place
value but here you can view it as degree
places or something like that and then
you take that x and you multiply it
times this entire expression so x times
2 is 2x put that in the first degree
column x times x is
x squared
and then what we want to do is we want
to subtract these things in yellow from
what we originally had in blue so we
could do it this way
and then we will be left with 7x minus
2x is 5x
and then x squared minus x squared is
just a zero
and then we can bring down
this plus 10.
and once again we look at the highest
degree term x goes into 5x five times
that's a zero degree it's a constant so
i'll write it in the constant column
5 times 2 is 10
5 times x is 5 and then i'll subtract
these from what we have up here and
notice we have no remainder what's
interesting about algebraic long
division we'll probably see in another
video or two you can actually have a
remainder so those are going to be
situations where just the factoring
technique alone would not have worked in
this situation this
this model would have been easier but
this is another way to think about it
you say hey look x plus 2 times x plus 5
is going to be equal to this now if you
wanted to rewrite this expression
the way we did here and say hey this
expression is equal to x plus 5 we would
have to constrain the domain you'd say
hey for all x's not equaling negative 2
for these to be completely identical
expressions